hey guys how's it going it's Justine
welcome to day two of CES and today we
are not actually going over to the
convention center we are the sands Expo
so this is kind of like an offshoot of a
convention center over here is a ton of
smart home tech which is my absolute
favorite
[Music]
so I found something that I'm really
into sweeping
[Music]
we're talking about smart sleep here at
the Philips booth now what exactly is
going on here because this looks very
high-tech oh it is very high-tech it's
actually our newest is a new two world
technology called smart sleep and what
it does it in the Hans's deep sleep and
people who typically get less than seven
hours of sleep a night has sensors on
the forehead behind the ear to track
your sleep and it sends a tone and that
tone has been hamptons those slow waves
and makes them long and strong again I
started freaking out I was like guys
it's David I just saw you walking we I
went to your show I think was like last
year I went through the tour of his
incredible Museum you gotta come back we
just redid a made of four times space
incredible please I would love to oh my
gosh they would be so awesome we just
talked about yesterday about all the
stuff that you're doing and it's great I
follow you for so long and this is so
great are you doing CES what I'm seeing
everything that's new you know of course
I use technology in my show yes
and I try to use technology where people
don't know it so even the inventors of
these things I disguise him the way so
yeah they're amazed by itself it's a
great place newspaper what do you do
there he is checking it out we're just
like covering and finding cool stuff
the iving the thing that I do love about
your show is he uses technology if you
guys have never seen a David Copperfield
show you have to go and just witness it
because it really is incredible and I
think you're pushing the boundaries as
far as magic technology and just
bringing the funds in space
[Music]
one of the things I love to do at CES is
obviously go around and find cool things
this booth behind me I have absolutely
no idea what it is
there's no branding it basically looks
like a huge Call of Duty map they gave
me a blindfold to go in and I know
nothing about what it is so I'm number
one slightly terrified number two
there's some security guards in the back
and it says authorized personnel only so
really I don't even know what to expect
oh that's some industrial velcro oh my
god now what is you I hear some music
Oh oh my gosh I have no idea what's
going on right now
please remove your blindfolds
[Music]
right now
are we still at SIA
[Music]
I am here of my own
no I don't know what I have no idea
where Nick is I don't know if I'm
talking to myself am I talking to the
camera Nick
I am here of my own free will
[Music]
excellent see it's just that easy so
volunteers for the procedures Oh
do we not most of all into your
volunteer almost tributes what have
happening right now over the future of
skin care what you just experienced was
a completely
we integrated into our newest release
REO being the largest beauty device
Graham we wanted to create something
that really broke barriers and what you
experienced was really that human
experience of what we're doing so I'm
sure you've seen people sit for 20
minutes in our masks we've done it
yourself oh yes definitely sons of the
masks challenges what you do so like you
experienced we have a cryotherapy which
is a cruel treatment in this we also
have the thermal therapy I just turned
the device on so it's a preheating we're
gonna start with thermal therapy when
you are at home you put the cartridge on
and you do it 90 minute treatment it's
warm
it goes up to 102 degrees Wow well
sequence it you'll scan your mask with
your phone and then that will program
your device that's so cool so so there's
basically an app for your mask now what
you're saying oh my goodness so and then
it'll go through and you'll feel some
pulsations which made us famous in our
cleansing device yeah DeLuna as well as
what you're seeing there with the red
light is RGB LED light therapy and so
what that does is stimulate cochin also
is age-defying
this is definitely not what I expected I
mean this is something that you see at
comic-con where you're running through
like a zombie maze and you're getting
attacked and then you come out with like
well no we've got a nice face mask for
you whoo this is the best zombie
apocalypse ever I don't want to spoil it
for anybody else but that was wild
[Music]
okay we probably should get one right
clickbait titles that is nice
[Music]
there's always fun little gems that I'll
find it but this is actually super
surprising I always use Philips
toothbrushes but look at this this is
something I didn't even know existed
this cup is the charge most people take
their toothbrush and just throw it in a
cup well now when you do it it's
actually functional this is charging the
toothbrush so this is called at the one
it's a smart piano and it's really cool
because it basically turns learning to
play in the piano into a game I just
tried to read sheet music for the first
time in my entire life and I managed to
play a song just LEDs that run along the
piano and they light up so it'll let you
know what you have to press and another
cool thing they said they've launched
here at CES is an LED panel so if you
already have a piano you can also use
the software auto open closed lid heated
seat dryer deodorizer Wow wait I made a
mistake when I started the CES videos I
should have been doing a while we factor
a while we from skills 1 to 10
[Music]
what's happening and how do I get that
outfit because it's incredible
[Music]
this was so shocking because like the
dress is changing colors it's kind of
like the dress like what color is the
dress is this just eating Tac Toe like
your Kindle reader but it's on a dress
how do I do it I don't know really how
to do that but that guy oh I'm not
really sure look forward to CES we ended
up at right now I'm not sure if I'm
comfortable or what's up
extinguisher gun this is the future I
mean it is a mirror and I do feel like
this is a future black mirror episode I
mean this mirror is connected to the
Internet I can use filters there's apps
it runs on Android Anna has a built-in
camera okay here we go I'll focus up
what this is running forgetting Windows
the simplest things
I am so easily entertained hey come look
at this sort of things that I'll
announce here at CES is gonna be doing
more third-party integrations so taking
the towel technology and putting it into
existing things like this this is a
Herschel wallet they made this custom so
it has a nice place for your towel to go
this is key smart it's not made by tile
but it's using the tile integration so
instead of attaching a keychain tile to
your keys you attach your keys to of
this awesome little keychain here well
that's not a key that's the popping
bottles there's a flashlight cool Wow
I'm enjoying so many of the small simple
things here is here so in some of the
newer wireless Bose headphones they have
tile built into it so you can just use
the tile app to find your headphones
this is probably one of the smartest
things that I've ever seen because how
many times you guys lose your Apple
remote all the time so one of the new
things that they also announced at CES
is tile integration with Google and
Alexa can you hear me so let's do like a
little demonstration I'd say that we
lost our keys we could say hey Google a
style to wring my keys sure
here's Baroness I'm where are my keys
oh right over there found them a style
to find my phone all right
over I found the amount of times that
I've heard that specific ringtone you
guys know I lose my phone a lot a style
where my backpack is your backpack was
lasted to 101 it would tell San Mateo of
where was last checked in so you can go
to that address
USA retrace your status find your
backpack we just got word that Shaq is
here and he's playing a video
so let's go see it I want to read by
tradition $10,000 purse
we saw him and now we leave okay one of
the things that I was really excited
about CES is finding smart doorbells but
it's really crazy because I can't find
any of them anywhere see that was a joke
guys because they are absolutely
everywhere every turn that you take
there are smart doorbells and smart
outdoor lights
it's wild now let's go because we're
already 15 minutes past the time that we
should be here we have started and end
of the day at Starbucks the only
difference between the end of CES is
normally the Starbucks line is all the
way wrapping around here all the way to
there but guess what nobody here now
baby just uh
[Music]